do not do to others what you do not want
done to
yourself real knowledge is to know the
extent of one's
[Music]
ignorance he who speaks without modesty
will find it difficult to make his words
good
[Music]
I hear and I forget I see and I remember
I do and I
[Music]
understand everything has Beauty but not
everyone sees
[Music]
it do not be ashamed of mistakes and and
thus make them
[Music]
crimes isn't it a pleasure to study and
practice what you have
[Music]
learned it is not possible for one to
teach others what he cannot teach his
own
family
[Music]
education breeds confidence confidence
breeds hope hope breeds
[Music]
peace without feelings of respect what
is there to distinguish men from
[Music]
Beasts
he who excels in study can follow an
official
[Music]
career forget injuries never forget
kindnesses we should feel sorrow but not
sink under its oppression
[Music]
recompense injury with Justice
recompense kindness with
[Music]
kindness better a diamond with a flaw
than a pebble without
[Music]
one to love a thing means wanting it to
live
to go beyond is as wrong as to fall
[Music]
short in a country well-governed poverty
is something to be ashamed
[Music]
of things that are done it is needless
to speak about things that are passed it
it is needless to
[Music]
blame looking at small advantages
prevents great affairs from being
[Music]
accomplished people may be made to
follow a path of action but they may not
be made to understand
it
when you have faults do not fear to
abandon
them the cautious seldom
air men's Natures are alike it is their
habits that carry them far
apart it is only only the wisest and the
stupidest that cannot
change the object of the superior man is
[Music]
truth the essence of knowledge is having
it to apply it not having it to confess
your
ignorance
a man who does not plan ahead will find
trouble at his
[Music]
door humility is the solid foundation of
all
virtues when anger arises think of the
[Music]
consequences
study the past if you would Define the
future to be wronged is nothing unless
you continue to remember
it the scholar who cherishes the love of
comfort is not fit to be deemed a
scholar
wheresoever you go go with all your
[Music]
heart the real fault is to have faults
and not amend
[Music]
them when we see men of a contrary
character we should turn inwards and
examine
ourselves
[Music]
a fool despises Good Counsel but a wise
man takes it to
heart he who will not economize will
have to
agonize I am not concerned that I am not
known I seek to be worthy to be known
[Music]
without an acquaintance with the rules
of propriety it is impossible for
character to be
[Music]
established mankind differs from the
animals only by little and most people
throw that
away
to see what is right and not to do it is
want of courage or a
[Music]
principle it is better to light one
small candle than to curse the
[Music]
darkness respect yourself and others
will respect
[Music]
you
when Prosperity comes do not use all of
it ignorance is the night of the mind
but a night without moon or
Star they must often change who would be
constant in happiness or
wisdom
the more man meditates upon good
thoughts the better will be his world
and the World At
Large we take great pains to persuade
others that we are happy than in
endeavoring to think so
ourselves if a man takes no thought
about about what is distant he will find
sorrow near at
[Music]
hand behave toward everyone as if
receiving a great
[Music]
guest what the superior man seeks is in
himself what the small man seeks is in
others
the strength of a Nation derives from
the Integrity of the
[Music]
home when you see a worthy person
Endeavor to emulate him when you see an
unworthy person examine your inner
self wealth and rank are what people
desire but unless they be obtained in
the right way they they may not be
[Music]
possessed The Wheel of Fortune turns
round incessantly who can say to himself
today I shall be
[Music]
uppermost the father who does not teach
his son his duties is equally guilty
with the son who neglects
them the parents age must be be
remembered both for joy and
[Music]
anxiety when I walk along with two
others from at least one I will be able
to
learn if you look into your own heart
you find nothing wrong there what is
there to
fear study the past if you would Divine
the
[Music]
future virtue is not left to stand alone
he who practices it will have
[Music]
neighbors think no Vice so small that
you may commit it and no virtue so small
that you may Overlook
[Music]
it do not worry about holding High
position rather worry about playing your
proper
[Music]
role do not impose on others what you
yourself do not
[Music]
desire acquire new knowledge whilst
thinking over old and you may become a
teacher of
others sincerity and Truth are the basis
of every
[Music]
virtue reviewing the old and deducing
the new makes a
teacher act with kindness and do not
expect
gratitude worry not that no one knows of
you seek to be worth
knowing
he who conquers himself is the mightiest
Warrior ability will never catch up with
the demand for
it to see and listen to The Wicked is
already the beginning of
[Music]
wickedness before you embark on a
journey of Revenge dig two
[Music]
graves a youth is to be regarded with
respect how do you know that his future
will not be equal to your
present fix your mind on Truth hold firm
to Virtue rely on loving kindness and
find your recreation in the
[Music]
Arts
boldness without the rules of propriety
becomes
insubordination fine words and
insinuating appearance are seldom
associated with true
virtue learn as though you would never
be able to master hold as though you
would be in fear of
losing
I am not one who was born in the
possession of
knowledge I am one who is fond of
antiquity and Earnest in seeking it
[Music]
there when you know a thing to hold that
you know it and when you do not know a
thing to allow that you do not know it
this is
[Music]
knowledge the fault of a superior person
are like the sun and moon they have
their faults and everyone sees them they
change and everyone looks up to
them when a man's knowledge is
sufficient to attain and his virtue is
not sufficient to enable him to hold
whatever he may have gained he will
lose to be able under all circumstances
to practice five things constitutes
perfect virtue these five things are
gravity generosity of Soul sincerity
earnestness and
[Music]
kindness do not be desirous of having
things done quickly do not look at small
advantages desire to have things done
quickly prevents their being done
thoroughly
[Music]
the will to win the desire to succeed
the urge to reach your full potential
these are the keys that will unlock the
door to personal
[Music]
Excellence he with whom neither slander
that gradually soaks into the Mind nor
statements that startle like a wound in
the flesh is successful and may be
called intelligent indeed
[Music]
there are three things to beware of
through life when a man is Young let him
beware of his appetites when he is
middle-aged of his passions when old of
[Music]
covetousness virtue is more to man than
neither water or fire I have seen men
die from treading on water and fire
but I have never seen a man die from
treading the course of
virtue if I am walking with two other
men each of them will serve as my
teacher I will pick out the good points
of the one and imitate them and the bad
points of the other and correct them in
myself there is no right amount of sex
and giv giving up sex for a long time
shouldn't have negative side
effects to put the world in order we
must first put the nation in order to
put the nation in order we must first
put the family in order to put the
family in order we must cultivate our
personal life and to cultivate our
personal life we must first set our
hearts
right
isn't it also great when friends visit
from distant places if one Remains Not
annoyed when he is not understood by
people around him is he not a
sage with coarse rice to eat with water
to drink and my bended arm for a pillow
I still have joy in the midst of these
things riches and honors acquired by
unright rightousness are to me as a
floating
cloud